au conservatoire de saint benoît dans la
belle salle gramoun lélé c'est
aujourd'hui une rencontre très
importante c'est le championnat
académique de danse contemporaine et de
hip hop
donc qui réunit aujourd'hui 15 collèges
et lycées de toute la réunion et à
l'issue de cette journée les premiers
seront qualifiés pour partir au
championnat de france
ah ah
m
la danse c'est vrai que c'est une
discipline artistique donc vraiment sur
l'image de leur corps gérer ses émotions
essayé de donner aussi de l'émotion donc
d'ailleurs on a la chair de poule en
regardant certaines chorégraphies et
voilà à pouvoir passer devant une grande
salle devant 500 personnes vont là où
j'en étais pas forcément rempli mais
voilà il ya beaucoup d'élèves
j'entendais qui dise madame j'ai peur de
passer
voilà c'était bien mais on avait
beaucoup de stress mais c'est super
quand même on se fait plaisir on peut
mentonnais travail devant tout le monde
et on a un peu de stress qui monte
on a fait son beurre de remettre plus de
50 heures de répétition c'est la culture
mais dans chaque établissement les
professeurs en unss travail avec lancé
l'air montrent leurs chorégraphies et le
jour là c'est un gros enjeu pour eux en
fait ils sont nombreux il n'y a qu'une
seule place pour partir au championnat
de france aucun gros travail des
professeurs des élèves est également des
jeunes officiels qu'ils jugent
aujourd'hui les chorégraphies de leurs
camarades
regardez votre fonds vous n'avez pas
l'habitude de cette règle a mené vous
allez l'utiliser en raccrochant 7 rue du
lac et une feuille de danse
contemporaine est ce que vous faites
avec la battle est ce que vous
connaissez du nord
ces élèves ont dit tous capables et ces
élèves là on leur a pas dit souvent dans
leur vie qu'ils étaient capables et un
jour j'ai découvert dans le gymnase qui
les animait des ateliers
non pas pour eux mais pour les autres
qui étaient pavant et c'est comme ça que
j'ai fait la connaissance de tous ses
élèves
en général les entraînements c'est
presque tous les joueurs et même on a
besoin de s'entraîner donc même quand on
est au lycée les midis on va la salle de
sport et on s'entraîne on continue
s'entraîner à chaque fois c'est pour ça
que notre professeur hebbadj a comme qui
dirait repérer les projets c'est déjà de
partir en france pour une affaire de
principe est advenu académique de danse
nationale
ben on essaie donner de l'argent pour ce
6ème ses yeux de récolter de récolter
des fonds par par tous les moyens
genre par exemple le 26 avril nous
allons faire
l'ensemble dansant adaci
on va voir si fait certes on va donner
vraiment le maximum pour pour avoir
vraiment les meilleurs résultats ont tué
des rêves de la jeunesse en ce moment c
est la vie peuvent avoir un rêve
ils peuvent le vivre aujourd'hui
j'espère qu'il le vivront jusqu'à leur
fin la fin de leurs jours
je pense que c'est une belle expérience
pour eux et puis d'être dans une jolie
salle comme ça plutôt que dans leur
salle de classe ou dans leur gymnase
salle échanges